Rob here with a GS news update just days
before the official reveal of the next
call of duty game the game's release
date has been leaked everything has been
leaked according to the leaked info call
duty black ops 3 campaign has been
designed for co-op and replayability
with support up to four players online
the different characters are fully
customizable ranging from weapons and
loadouts two outfits multiplayer will
feature a momentum based movement system
with new jumps slides and mantling
abilities the game will also include a
zombie mode like previous Call of Duty
titles with its own separate storyline
and progression system a leak earlier
today of a gamestop display for black
ops 3 revealed the game's release date
as november six anyone who pre-orders a
pc xbox one or ps4 version of the game
will get pre-release beta access no
mention was made of previous generation
consoles Activision still plans to
unveil call of duty black ops 3
officially on Sunday with a trailer but
in any case you go ahead and you check
out gamespot.com / news where we're
gonna have all of that black ops 3
content I know I will
you